did you sense that we were gonna about
to play race my case
no i didn't oh that's we haven't done
this in a hot segment yeah that does
give me a lilly wreck
i know yeah chill out though yeah
i feel weird all right the first case
an online store owner traveled 530 miles
to beat up a female customer who made a
complaint about late delivery
the online shopper was beaten into a
concussion by the merchant the seller
traveled a day and night
from east to uh to the south to seek
revenge
he showed up a week later to attack the
customer before giving her at the close
attacker has been giving a 10-day
detention and his online store was
suspended oh not bad
i'm gonna go white why dude has that
just that fire inside to travel through
the night get there and beat the [ __ ]
out of somebody
i don't know it sounds very mercenary i
don't know what mercenary is but
it sounds very like um
i'm gonna say asian wow
he said well chin's offended yeah
i'm going to say asian chin you know i
just immediately saw a black person
i just that's just what i saw okay you
can say it that's fine okay
racist but that's no no i'm just kidding
chappelle uh i'm gonna say white i don't
think black
i don't think a black person is gonna
spend all that energy it's a lot of work
that's a lot of work
yeah you know when you could just press
the issue on site like right there
then it's fine but to travel that far i
agree with theo i see like an asian man
beating a white woman for some reason
yeah that's fair because if it's a white
guy or white girl they just try and get
them cancelled on social media
they wouldn't drive by fair point cat
and theo got it right
but we're gonna ask you guys get more
specific oh
we're kind of asian i'm gonna say korean
i don't want to agree with you i agree
yep i'm gonna go korean as well you got
that han
it was a chinese guy oh [ __ ] dude
and we do fake news nick
we do a video of the attack oh
oh it's an asian woman oh it's in china
this makes perfect sense
that makes sense oh whoa whoa whoa
nobody told me these are international
stories i would have said chinese all
day
oh he can't tell you that he robbed her
he did quite the combo yeah oh never
mind he had that wait about me
i thought he played about my store and
this is in another country nick yeah
this is china
wow i didn't know where you're going to
international waters
we have we have that's crazy i thought
it was always america
r.i.p man okay uh so
uh we'll say 1-1 tie between cat and
theo
or you got two all right all right all
right uh
we had a thief
robbed a convenience store with
watermelon on their head
as a disguise that's such a white thing
to do
i know where you're going if it's on the
head
it's dicey where you're going i'm not
going anywhere it literally looks right
at his
unique disguise you did that with me
earlier too he looked right at me when
he realized asian
i can't i'm just trying to connect i get
it
there's a moment where we all fall
victim man uh
i'm gonna go with urban gentlemen i'm
gonna go with white
that's someone who's everybody uh
watermelon on the head i would have to
say white just let's see
that's why it's black cat
i'm gonna shake it up and say something
latino oh can i change mine to black
yes it was a
white guy wow wow [ __ ]
and that is cultural appropriation also
i want to go out and say that
that's the whitest part about this crime
yes
did he get canceled for it oh out of
masks robbers wore watermelons
let's see a uh a guy stole lottery
tickets and then try to cash them
at the same store dumbass
so they put a watermelon on his head no
this is different oh
oh god so wait what happened yeah what
happened with the other one uh
they got caught with the watermelon on
their head and stealing stuff
sounds like you don't know but go on
they found them i
don't know sure we didn't have a picture
of them though
let's see a uh police arrested a man who
stole
uh scratch off tickets from a
convenience store and then went to the
same store
to try to cash them for just over a
hundred dollars
black with the cop trying to catch on no
no the
the they caught the guy trying to catch
him black
and he did it hours apart first he
cashed the 30 that he stole then a
couple hours later i would say black
black
yeah you think so what makes you say
that chappelle what makes you think that
yeah we don't have justified really but
by people like lottery tickets yeah
it's the scratch scratch-offs the
scratches been doing that for ages
yeah she's been doing that for a minute
older generations like them too i think
i'll go black bingo is more of a white
thing right
i'll go black i think so scratch off
more black actually you know what i'm
going white
i'm going black black cat same black
latino he was black
wow you should have saved man you should
have stayed
that's crazy to do to do it at one place
and then they come right back and try to
cash them it's just so brazen
stupid unless he has dementia like maybe
he's unwell
yeah probably we can't give him benefit
of the doubt man
probably and we got a picture of him
i don't know if it's ad block or this i
swear if it's my dad
[Laughter]
oh there's no black in that picture he
does not look like he has dementia
though
you don't think so you could he has
something else i just don't think it's
dementia
he has some problems it's a gambling
problem for sure
is